for zachary one of liverpool's most
deprived neighborhoods
this food bank helped people keep going
through the first
lockdown now stocking up as the second
wave hits
anxiety here about the long winter ahead
it's terrifying i nearly lost my dad
through this and it's pretty terrifying
so
some of the people are going to come out
of this are going to be different
extremes
some people have been massively affected
by it people have buried people
and it's scary to think that we haven't
got it under control we haven't got the
proper measures in place
liverpool's pubs and bars forced to
close and household mixing band
but this volunteer says the local
lockdown won't be enough
we need to go into a total lockdown not
liverpool not merseyside
not the liberal city legion we need to
lock down the whole country
unfortunately i think the vast majority
of liverpool probably be of the opinion
that the government actually can say is
more concerned
about the economy than its citizens the
labour leader agrees with dave
this morning the telegraph quotes senior
government sources
saying the chances of the prime minister
backing a circuit break in the next two
weeks
or about 80 percent is that right
and if it is why doesn't it do it now
save lives fix testing and protect the
nhs
i rule out nothing of course in in
combating
the virus but we are going to do it with
the local the regional
approach that can drive down and will
drive
down the virus if it is properly
implemented
greater manchester one of the regions
under pressure to join liverpool in tier
three
but local leaders say this will do more
harm than good
local business unconvinced too tony had
supported boris johnson
but now worries the government's lost
its way some of this
now that's coming out it just doesn't
make any sense why a 10 o'clock curfew
what's that actually doing what you know
what's the purpose behind it where is it
getting us we've got this 10 o'clock
curfew and figures are still going up so
the 10 o'clock curve clearly isn't
working is it
you're losing faith a bit yeah
definitely decisions being made hundreds
of miles away in westminster having
real-life
impact on millions of people across the
north of england people here
in rochdale in liverpool in wigan in
leeds
and what they want is some real
certainty
and leadership in these very very
unpredictable times
earlier in the year we were all in it
together but now we're growing evermore
apart
ours are country divided not just over
how
best to beat the second wave but in how
we're being forced to live
beth rigby sky news manchester
but